the Soviets given their idea of class
guilt which sounds a lot like white
privilege to me or any other form of
racism they use that doctrine to just
round up all the kulaks
they were the productive farmers and
shipped them off to Siberia and then six
million Ukrainians starved to death but
you know they had too many Ukrainians
anyway so it didn't really matter so
many ways back to the postmodern types
well you know this all came was revealed
in such painful detail that even the
kind of closed-minded ideologue that
norman referred to just quite couldn't
couldn't quite muster up the moral
courage to keep beating the same damn
drum so what they did instead being
highly intelligent individuals was play
a game of sleight of hand and
transformed these Marxist
presuppositions into post-modernism in
the 1970s and the idea basically was
well the working class isn't going to
rise up and crush the burgeois z because
first of all they're getting rich and
that wasn't supposed to happen
second well it sort of seemed to be a
catastrophe when that occurred let's say
in Russia and so maybe we won't do that
anymore because the working class
actually isn't buying into this either
which is also a problem you know having
internalized their own oppression they
wouldn't buy into this to the global
myth of utopia so maybe it's because
they had some sense it's certainly
possible but anyways the sleight-of-hand
was oh well fine we'll just play a
different oppressor versus oppressed
gained and we'll introduce identity
politics it's like okay okay you're not
being oppressed because you remember the
working class you're being oppressed
because you're a woman or you're being
oppressed because you have an ethnicity
that's outside the main paradigm
whatever that might be or it's because
of your your your sexual preference or
your sexual identity whatever whatever
places you in some manner outside the
normative culture and you know the thing
is the postmodernist
you know you might think well your
culture is good for something it gives
you a hierarchy value it rewards
competent people it gives you a
direction so you can climb up you know
because otherwise everything's leveled
to nothing and then why do anything I
don't care about any of that they don't
believe that there's any such thing as
competence they don't believe that
there's any such thing is up this is all
post-modernism wipes all of that out and
so when the postmodernist analyzed the
text all they care about is how it
privileges the position of the author
and who it impresses and that's the only
thing they regard is real and they don't
believe in grand unifying narratives
they don't believe that there's a
Canadian identity they don't believe
that there's an American identity they
don't believe that there's a Western
identity they don't believe that value
structures exist or if they are they're
replaceable to some other value
structure they certainly don't believe
that they have any biological grounding
that there's any such thing as a human
being it's all socially constructed
which is really convenient if what you
want to do is be the author of an
entirely social construct a new utopia
that you can run